[Música]
buenas bienvenidos una vez más a esta
emisión de canadá en las américas café
el programa que les ofrece cada semana
el servicio en español de radio canadá
internacional con estas imágenes de
distintos sitios del país que ustedes
están viendo que nos acompañan en la
apertura de este programa semana a
semana
hoy estamos aquí en el estudio de honor
al chapman hola pablo gómez barrios
hola alves ya la haya- a todo el otro
lado del micrófono y de las cámaras
leonardo gimeno que tal buenas tardes
buenos días buenas noches se anda
cambiando de nombres a los padres
diseñar y mi nombre es luis laborda
además ustedes lo pueden ver allí en la
otra punta de la mesa tenemos un
invitado a quien los memoriosos ya
recordaran estuvo hace muy poco con
nosotros
emisión que hicimos desde el salón de la
inmigración hace tan solo algunas
semanas es gabriel garcía del centro
para la inmigración en región en el
centro
muchas gracias por la invitación y vamos
a hablar en unos instantes más de un
evento que están organizando para la
semana próxima
así que ya nos vamos a referir a ese
tema hay alguna algún ruido extraño que
está ocurriendo por harina y un fichaje
de junts y ya está pero ya se pasó
espero que no les ha roto el oído a
nadie porque eso suele pasar también
antes de adentrarnos en el tema que
vamos a desarrollar con nuestro invitado
queríamos recordar que hoy 21 de junio
se celebra que pasó el solsticio el
solsticio por un lado sí aunque eso no
es una buena noticia para los que amamos
el verano y el sol porque implica que la
luz solar empieza ya a decrecer hay
menos tiempo de solar no es el solsticio
del solcito sí que se hace desear no
pero además hoy se conmemora el
nacional de los pueblos originarios aquí
en canadá o de los pueblos indígenas o
de los pueblos autóctonos como ustedes
le quieran decir ahí vemos algunas
imágenes de eventos que se han realizado
es un día en el que se intenta reconocer
el rol que los pueblos originarios
juegan o deberían jugar en el conjunto
de la sociedad canadiense y es también
una ocasión para reflexionar sobre los
desafíos que todavía tenemos pendientes
en cuanto a mejoras que debería deberían
producirse hacia el trato el
reconocimiento sabemos que ha habido
casos de violencia casos de olvido hacia
esa comunidad indígena de este país si
ustedes ven ahí una imagen que yo la
coloque porque me llamó la atención es
un famoso tótem indígena que yo tenía
muy grabado en mí y en mi retina antes
mucho antes siquiera de pensar en venir
a vivir a canadá y era para mí un
símbolo canadiense el tótem indígena era
para mí el símbolo
resolvía nada no es cierto y yo tenía la
imagen no sé si del todo erróneo tampoco
por tampoco tampoco que sea tan negativo
de que canadá era un pueblo en el cual
los indígenas eran los privilegiados no
es así sabemos que la situación dista
mucho de ser una situación agradable
para los pueblos indígenas pero bueno la
fecha está la conmemoración está el
recuerdo para ellos está el
reconocimiento está y en algunos casos
también los pedidos de resarcimiento al
daño que se les ha infligido por no hay
que olvidar perdón
hay que recordar que recientemente
además se presentó un informe
una investigación que se vino haciendo
en canadá desde hace algunos años sobre
la violencia ejercida contra las mujeres
indígenas asesinadas y desaparecidas y
ese informe que se presentó hace dos
semanas fue calificado directamente como
un genocidio contra las mujeres
indígenas algo que incluso el primer
ministro canadiense había dicho y
aceptado esa definición de genocidio
cultural oral al principio
pérez indígenas de todas las ciudades de
todas niñas adultas y que pues
justamente siguen desaparecidas o siguen
siendo asesinadas porque no lo quería
simplemente agregar louis con respecto a
esa percepción que tenían de que los
indígenas eran privilegiados en el fue
en efecto lo fueron hasta la llegada del
hombre blanco
hace 500 más de 500 años una historia
repetida en distintos puntos no
solamente en canadá si para mí
el tótem no era la referencia de canadá
sino era el linux que después supe en
realidad esa formación
pero si le decía animales esquimales a
que ellos se niegan a ser llamados
espinales porque ese fue el nombre que
le pusieron los extranjeros que llegaron
a canadá y que significa literalmente
comedores de carne cruda no es
peyorativo un poco ese nombre ellos son
inuit que quiere decir gente y para
terminar lo que estabas diciendo sobre
los tótem una vez recuerdo que fuimos a
columbia británica al famoso paganos los
jaivas y otras naciones indígenas ahí
supimos cómo los hacían y finalmente
sólo ellos lo que hacían era derribar
los árboles más altos y más
unidos y derribados los empezaban a
tallar y hacían todas estas grabaciones
grabados sobre maderas y eso está bien
tienen historias tienen significados y
precisamente el trote aunque habíamos
ahí en las imágenes es de columbia
británica y lo que me acuerdo me estoy
acordando ahora en realidad es que en la
buenos aires en la plaza de retiro una
de las plazas más céntricas de la ciudad
que ahora no recuerdo exactamente el
nombre que tiene pero después de la
guerra de malvinas se le cambió el
nombre porque además ahí estaba lo que
en su momento o hasta lo que hasta ese
momento se conocía como la torre de los
ingleses después con la guerra de
malvinas y esas denominaciones fueron
modificándose en la última plazoleta de
la plaza del retiro hay un tótem erigido
que fue valorado por canadá la arena 6 y
que de alguna manera simboliza para
muchísimos argentinos es más que
simbolizar es el icono de canadá y que
con eso quisieron significar las
relaciones que existen que se hace no sé
cuántos años exactamente relaciones
diplomáticas entre argentina y canadá
me gustaría agregar con respecto a los
inukshuk de los que mencionaba nuestro
querido leonardo y algo que me ha
intrigado siempre bueno primero que los
uno que servían para orientarse en el
hielo para eso los construían o sea era
era una forma de
encontrar su camino en medio de esa
inmensidad de hielo
congelada y en el norte de canadiense
pero lo que siempre me intrigó era de
dónde diablos se acababan las piedras
porque están hecho con una piedras
enormes además liii y ese suelo está
congelado ahí no hay piedras entonces
siempre me intrigó el cómo hicieron para
llevar esas piedras bueno me imagino que
en la época con rastreaban también los
transportaban porque es como hago dice
será significa significaba por aquí
pasamos entonces apuntan a una dirección
que significa hay que ir por esta
dirección y en general el verso rector y
en general hay una la forma como los
construían era que había un hueco la
iban orientaba a las piedras hacia la
dirección donde querían que querían
indicar y en la ponía cuando hacen el
linux con un hueco en el medio para
decir la dirección que tenían que tomar
cuando miraba es a través de ahí miraba
en la dirección que las que tenía que
seguir si esas figuras incluso se
encuentran reproducidas en algunas casas
incluso aquí en el material de los he
visto y se sembró sal en la ribera sur
donde yo vivo hay vecinos que tienen
esas imágenes reproducidas no sé si
porque ellos tendrán algún parentesco o
algo de sangre indígena o no o si será
simplemente un homenaje a los pueblos
indígenas a los pueblos originarios de
este país bueno en todo caso sea como
sea está mostrando la línea hecho y ahí
tienen imagen podemos ver un anuncio y
no imaginar lo que va a ponchar en este
ambiente ahí en el medio se mirada se
ponía de frente y miraba en el medio y
te indicaba la dirección que debía ser
yo me imagino viendo esa fotografía que
en los momentos de verano en los
deshielos probablemente las piedras
también salían a la superficie en
algunos lugares porque esto acordate
cuando estuvimos en una bud pablo que es
lo que me había sorprendido en una
botella nos dijeron los habitantes los
inuit dijeron
aunque nos hicimos conocidos los voy a
llevar a conocer un parque que tenemos
en iqaluit y cuando llegamos al parque
era pura piedra o sea había lugares para
sentarse armado con piedra había caminos
con piedra pero es algo que nunca no
estamos acostumbrados a ver nosotros
fuimos hace dos años atrás nomás cuatro
años atrás momentos de perdón y mis
hijos
hicieron en el medio de mentalidad a la
costa de un lago super hermoso en la
provincia de mendoza 3 y noche
bueno es un tema que me apasiona a mí
también a los pueblos indígenas
obviamente como decíamos una historia
muy similar a la que tuvimos en toda
américa y bueno méxico hace parte de esa
gran riqueza cultural indígena de toda
la américa entonces yo solamente para
invitar a la gente que nos está los
radioescuchas que nos están escuchando
en este momento y bueno que nos
escucharan después en realización y todo
eso solamente escuchando y viendo y
también exacto que una gran una gran
oportunidad de entrar en contacto con
esos pueblos
son los que ahora se le llaman para guau
son como mini festivales y hay toda una
ruta que es súper súper rica de hacerla
no va habiendo un pub en diferentes
comunidades indígenas por todo el que ve
por todo cuando yo sé cuál es el motivo
de hacer un paraguay pues parece ser que
son precisamente reuniones como es un
forum de diversidad cultural donde hay
este a través de la danza en
manifestaciones sobre todo la danza y
cantos que vienen de todos los pueblos
iniciaremos una ceremonia indígena sí
claro sí exactamente exactamente
entonces es muy muy importante de ir y
convivir no es una manera realmente de
entrar en contacto con los pueblos
indígenas y hay una variedad de
pahuatlán en todo lo ancho y largo de
quebec claro y una logo tenés algún
mensaje en realidad tengo mensajes
giovanni aventura dice estoy viendo a
partir de cabinda áfrica
en el nombre de giovani ventura bueno
muy bienvenidos giovanni y espero que no
siga habiendo y que invite a sus
cercanos allí no soy un bien después en
gilberto martínez saludos desde
nicaragua alexis caicedo desde
buenaventura colombia saludos
gustavo lucas saludos desde la ciudad de
medio departamento de cerro largo
uruguay es un placer ver y escuchar sus
programas español francés e inglés y
manfred echevarría dice belka luiste
tiene aspectos son muy interesantes no
da gana le pegan a uno por vivir ahí no
le da gana le pagan a uno por vivir ahí
así que hay un cambio importante
y bueno muy bien además de como digo
siempre además de youtube de facebook
live que son los canales habituales por
los que nos pueden seguir está
recuérdenlo la vieja y querida página de
radio canadá internacional www brc y net
punto sea a quienes opten por esa opción
como es habitual tendrán dos temas
música
que no disfrutarán quiénes están
siguiendo en este momento a través de
youtube o de facebook live en este caso
los artistas canadienses zafia nolan y
karim el artista canadiense caribou
googlette con dos temas musicales en el
primer caso le llenan el camino y en el
segundo caso
karim el loop karim y el logo que van a
estar en la edición de nuestro sitio
internet que estará disponible en poco
tiempo más en una hora y media más o
menos dos horas tal vez estará en línea
y permanecerá allí hasta la primera hora
o hasta bien entrada la mañana del día
lunes durante todo el fin de semana
cariño el logo quizás hace referencia a
ese famoso cuento no de pie del luthier
y él lo pedro y el ebro y el logo éste
es un artista que se mete dentro de un
disfraz de lobo y sale a la calle y vive
algunas aventuras a cazar agua a partir
de eso no precisamente no precisamente
bueno hecha la invitación entonces para
que nos sigan a través las diversas
plataformas que tenemos a disposición
la semana vamos a darle ahora sí
oficialmente o formalmente la bienvenida
a nuestro invitado en el día de hoy
decíamos que se trata de gabriel garcía
que ya estuvo con nosotros en el salón
de la inmigración que hicimos hace
algunas semanas atrás y gabriel voz nos
venía a hablar hoy un evento que están
preparando que se va a llevar a cabo el
29 de junio me equivoco exactas y en la
región de la que tú vienes de qué se
trata este evento así es bueno
yo represento perdón representa el
centro para la inmigración en la región
que es un organismo sin fines de lucro
que ya tiene dos años trabajando con la
ms euros ante lo que es la municipalidad
regional del condado si se puede
traducir así de arrancar esta región
está situada a una hora y media de
trayecto en auto en autobús o en
automóvil
hacia el norte d
de montreal y bueno estamos ahí
organizando este evento cultural con la
finalidad de promover la región darle
como una vitrina más porque me imagino
que muchos de los radioescuchas y de las
personas que nos ven por todas las redes
sociales dijeron y bueno dónde está eso
ese condado de realmente esto es
precisamente por eso en este momento hay
muchas muchas oportunidades que se están
desarrollando de más en más en en
pequeñas ciudades y pequeños
municipalidades en todo lo largo de
quebec porque bueno la realidad es que
la población de quebec que empieza a
envejecer
y el fenómeno de que como en todo el
mundo los jóvenes
del campo van hacia los grandes centros
urbanos a buscar los servicios de
educación y generalmente no regresan a
sus regiones de origen hasta ya después
de muchos años entonces todo eso genera
de ciertos problemas de vaciamiento de
personas también en la edad de trabajar
exactamente entonces ahora en la región
estamos teniendo una campaña como para
prevenir todas esas problemáticas en ese
momento no hay una como 'alerta roja'
como ella en otras regiones de quebec
pero nosotros estamos tratando de
contribuir a eso a hacer que empieza a
ver una cierta vitrina para para dar a
conocer la región que está a una hora no
de montreal y seguir casi y que bueno
representa una buena opción para que las
personas y familias inmigrantes empiecen
a llegar no a la región y que eso
también genere como un intercambio
cultural y obviamente enriquezcan
según nosotros y la m hace también está
de acuerdo con nosotros de enriquecer la
la cultura la la economía también y en
sí toda la región de hecho en la
información que visita llegar al
respecto de este evento dice que la
fiesta se presenta como una ocasión para
promover la atracción la instalación y
la integración de personas y familias
inmigrantes en el territorio de
municipios regionales frentes ya sea que
se trate de personas que están ya
recibiendo en lugar como de aquellas que
están planeando irse a vivir allí porque
la región sigue recibiendo gente no es
exactamente la llegada de inmigrantes se
ha detenido y mucho menos no exactamente
como habíamos platicado ya en el salón
de inmigración en nuestra región
al todo el tiempo recibido de personas y
carnés inmigrantes pero no están como
todavía identificadas no están censadas
entonces también esta es una ocasión de
invitarlos y de decirles bueno vengan y
podemos trabajar en conjunto para ver
las necesidades que ustedes tienen en
una región porque desafortunamente como
decíamos
y hay algunos inconvenientes de vivir es
una región que es muy agrícola que
también ese es nuestro propósito de
promover la agricultura por eso es que
es el nombre de la fiesta agricultura el
que dijimos en francés entonces el
objetivo es ese no precisamente crear un
foro de interacción entre las personas
que ya están establecidas ahí la gente
de arranque de la comunidad de
acogimiento como podemos llamarle las
personas inmigrantes que ya tienen ahí
muchos años y que están un poquito y
perdidas que que no tienen como una
cierta vitrina y las personas que
estamos precisamente tratando de atraer
entonces va a haber un autobús
precisamente también el 29
de junio que va a salir de aquí de
montreal para todas aquellas personas
que quieran visitar la región a través
de este de este festival
y bueno la programación es muy
interesante no va a haber juegos
inflables para los niños actividades
como talleres de malabarismo padres e
hijos va a haber también un
percusionista de origen francés que hace
talleres de percusión africana también
para los niños va a ver como pintura
como le llaman acá pintura en directo
donde la gente va a poder participar
para hacer murales y todo participativos
va a ver obviamente grupos musicales va
a estar el grupo salsa descalza con
nosotros que son unas chicas colombianas
y hay una que otra quebequense ahí que
hacen un espectáculo de danza y después
invitan a la gente a unirse al
espectáculo entonces es una algo muy
participativo no precisamente para crear
esa esa comunión no entre la gente de
acogida y las personas inmigrantes
si yo tendría una pregunta gabriel vos
hiciste un poco el camino contrario a lo
que hacen la mayoría de los inmigrantes
viniste de méxico pero no te
en las grandes ciudades canadienses te
fuiste a esa zona porque bueno yo como
todos como todo el mundo así me instalé
primeramente
me di cuenta que había precisamente
retomando otra vez la riqueza en las
regiones la me di cuenta a través de los
pagos porque yo empecé a vender mi
artesanía mexicana bueno yo soy artesano
entonces en mis tiempos libres se hacían
con el artesanía y como yo me interesó
en los pueblos indígenas
empecé a visitar los paraguayos y fue
como empezar a descubrir la riqueza
cultural que hay en los pequeños pueblos
no entonces es así que me empezó a
interesar la la región y es así como que
bueno pues yo probé varias regiones no
estuve viviendo un poco en el amor y si
cerca detrás rivière casi estuvo a punto
de instalarme en gas pésimo y hasta que
bueno exactamente que se esté a una hora
de montreal no y cuando necesitamos una
dosis de
de ciudad se regresa después a la
tranquilidad del campo a dormir y como
dices es una zona bien agrícola sobre
todo agrícola los inmigrantes que llegan
ahí de dónde vienen bueno pues en este
momento tenemos identificadas familias
obviamente hay muchas familias de
colombia empieza a haber familias
mexicanas que se han establecido allí
hemos identificado también hay una
pequeña comunidad es exitoso sea
comunidad porque decidió instalarse en
un verdaderamente están como aislados en
una pequeña comunidad de lituania pero
parece que es bastante en hombros
numerosas numerosa entonces bueno están
por ahí está un poco perdido no hay y
también hay algo muy chistoso que hay
hay un templo tibetano que es el más
grande de quebec en en nuestra región
allí está y está ahí es cuando dictó
tres cosas interesa
monjes tibetanos y de vez en cuando
reciben a nivel internacional y debe ser
la naturaleza porque está claro
ordinaria esa naturaleza saliendo de acá
una hora de montreal es bosques son aves
y es una combinación de campos bosques y
una zona montañosa entonces la es
riquísimo por allá tenemos también
atracciones turísticas como lo son
el río de utah ue desagüe y la riviera
roja o la riviera que atraen muchos
turistas a nivel de rating de habla de
lava para bajar los rápidos a las aguas
rápidas inundaciones si obviamente
también hubo una pequeña esta inundación
de hecho hay un hay una presa de
hidroeléctrica de hidro que ve que es un
poco vieja las instalaciones y se temía
que podría reventar xenón entonces
afortunadamente le resistió pero bueno
de más en más empezamos a tener también
ese pequeño problema de inundaciones
pero bueno no no pone en peligro a toda
la región obviamente es solamente las
personas que están y que están
directamente instaladas
en el borde de la riviera roja ahora en
ocasión del salón habíamos empezado a
tratar la problemática se habla se habla
continuamente del tema de la
erradicación en región es un poco de
demanda que hacen las autoridades tanto
aquí en la provincia de québec como a
nivel nacional de que la inmigración sea
orientada precisamente hacia las
regiones y que el inmigrante no se siga
concentrando en la gran ciudad pero
radicarse en una región tiene sus
desafíos también sí claro no todo es
color de rosa como decíamos hace un
momento
entonces bueno hay bastantes ventajas de
vivir en la región uno tiene acceso a la
propiedad más fácilmente no sea las
casas habitaciones están alrededor de
200 mil dólares con un buen jardín un
terreno bastante bastante grande donde
puedes tener tu jardín de tu huerto de
verduras o de legumbres para quien le
asuste el precio quienes estemos esté
viendo o escuchando del exterior y
ajuste del precio digamos que 200 mil
dólares es fácilmente un tercio del
valor de cualquier propiedad por ejemplo
en una ciudad como montreal para no
hablar de toronto de vancouver son mucho
más caros
exactamente y bueno estamos hablando
también de que con el precio de que uno
se compra una casa aquí digamos de unos
cuantos
quinientos mil dólares a lo mejor una
casa más o menos aquí no es familiar
bueno con eso haya estado comprando hace
una pequeña gran gran fernet como le
dice una llave lo que podría producir
algo común para todas aquellas personas
que se interesan también a desarrollar
un negocio en agricultura que es también
nuestro propósito de promover la
agricultura la mano de obra y escuelas
como empresarios en escuelas para los
niños claro está el condado de arrancado
y está dividido en nueve municipalidades
entonces sí exacto y esto se da como con
el tiempo de las grandes funciones no
que vimos en todo que ver qué hacen aquí
en montreal cuando se fusionaron
en algunos barrios de castilla y todo
eso también en las regiones se
fusionaron entonces dieron a los
condados no la mc que se llama entonces
está representada por nueve ciudades y
la más grande es la sur y los puntos
negativos bueno uno de los puntos
negativos que yo podría identificar y
para no mentir sería el río aportes no
el frío es más o menos relativamente y
es un poco como de montreal no porque
estamos en una hora entonces no cambia
mucho obviamente pero no yo pienso que
es más bien el transporte no el
transporte colectivo obviamente es casi
nulo no existe el condado ha empezado a
poner un cierto un cierto transporte que
está ahí a disposición de la gente pero
está como bajo llamada no hay que uno
que llamar para decir necesito este día
que vengan por mí a mi domicilio para ir
a trabajar que son porque son pequeñas
cosas pequeñas entre comillas hay que
tomar muy en cuenta pues por ejemplo yo
cuando llegué tampoco llegue
bueno llegué al destino a la región de
gatineau enfrente de la capital nacional
de ottawa nuestro lado de la provincia
de québec pero en frente de ottawa y
unas cosas que me impactó cuando llegué
una de las primeras cosas que me llamó
mucho la atención es que el el tránsito
de transporte público de autobús
circulaba en una dirección a la mañana y
en la dirección opuesta a la tarde por
lo que trabajaban es exactamente decir
se acabó eso que se da por ejemplo en el
caso de uno que viene en una gran ciudad
de que sale y se toma el autobús a los
primeros dos minutos estar esperando y
vuelve y saliva y viene cuando quiere
decir en las regiones eso no es así y el
tema del transporte es un tema que puede
llegar a complicar a que no estén los
vertidos hacia el que tenga dos
camionetas puede ponerse hacer
transporte y ganar también si eso es
también exactamente no porque nosotros
hacemos también un servicio de visitas
guiadas casi una o dos veces por mes y
mucha gente también es lo que
lo que dicen lo que lo que dice no hay
gente que los invitamos también a hacer
como un estudio de mercado al mismo
tiempo que visitan la región para ver si
pueden hacer cómo hacer un negocio allá
y mucha gente
claro exactamente y mucha gente es lo
que es lo que nos preguntan nos dice
identifican inmediatamente el problema
que les decimos el transporte y luego
luego dicen ay ay über aquí hay algunas
posibilidades de hacer negocio con esto
es decir desde luego está todo está
abierta ya no para abril antes de
retomar el tema de la fiesta programada
para la semana próxima quería volver a
un tema que tocamos también en el salón
y que recién nombrado y como al pasar
que a mí me llamó mucho la atención que
es tratándose de tu región en la región
agrícola no se encara el tema
como se lo hace tradicionalmente
respecto a la contratación de mano de
obra que trabaje en el campo sino que
ustedes están además muy conscientemente
y muy fuertemente impulsados hacia
lograr que cada persona se convierte en
su propio promotor en su propio
empresario en facilitar los
emprendimientos de tipo agrícola es así
así es exactamente también identificamos
esa esa problemática que en general yo
pienso que en todo el mundo la
agricultura es un
es un sector en el cual mucha gente no
pensamos
pienso que desafortunadamente algo muy
triste no porque hemos perdido el
contacto precisamente con nuestros
alimentos no ahora ya los los niños y
todos pensamos que ya es fácil de ir a
los estantes de los supermercados y
bueno ya compraste tu alimento pero no
sabemos lo que hay atrás de todo eso
entonces hemos perdido como es ese
sentido de contacto de comunión
con nuestros alimentos entonces para
todo país y nación es súper importante
no de tener acceso a la alimentación y
hay un fenómeno también que hemos estado
descubriendo que la población productiva
desde agrícola también sigue
envejeciendo
y si no hay como aquí le dicen un
recambio un recambio
heller no está ahí las nuevas
generaciones están más bien en la
tecnología entonces no quieren usar
nuestro género no cabe generalizar pero
una gran parte desde las nuevas
generaciones no quieren nada que ver con
la agricultura entonces ahí están de más
en más haciendo escasos también lo lo
center entre prender de los
emprendedores en la agricultura entonces
hay que nosotros estamos tratando de
aportar nuestro grano de arena de
resucitar testigos y sobre todo diciendo
a las personas fans inmigrantes que
podemos estar en la agricultura es un
sector muy difícil y complicado pero
bueno ahí están olvidando un grano de
arena en una semillita claro no queremos
decir perdón que es decir algunos
solamente quienes les de aire en el año
2050 dicen que beber 10 mil millones de
habitantes más o menos en el planeta es
decir la alimentación sigue siendo algo
fundamental
bueno al final podríamos auto
sustentarnos exactamente en jardines
dentro de algunos proyectos
en la ciudad no entre al uno pasa por
ciertos barrios hay lugares que son
lugares las huertas comunicables
comunitarias donde cada uno se tiene una
parcela una persona pequeña parcelita y
bueno hace plantar lo que quiera plantar
y después bueno canjea y cada uno
produce entre comidas por una cantidad
como para producir más sabrosos y
demasiado gatos por la gente de bien no
queremos lizarte mucho más porque
sabemos que tienes que volver a otras
regiones que lanzarte pronto a la ruta
entonces te pediría que recuerdes la
fecha el nombre del evento y que la
clave es a quienes no conocen o no
tienen forma de llegar en todo caso cómo
se puede hacer para
acercarse al lugar en exactamente
entonces buena semana el fin de semana
es el 29 es el sábado 29 de junio a
partir de las 10 se abre el sitio de
allá del festival entonces un festival
como decíamos que trata de promover la
región al mismo tiempo de promover el
bien
juntos la combi de las convivencias en
la región y para todas aquellas personas
que quieran descubrir la región tenemos
un autobús que va a salir a partir de
las 8 de la mañana el metro harry la
contribución voluntaria sugerida 15
dólares para cubrir los gastos del
autobús pero bueno si no no es problema
si usted no tiene el presupuesto para
para
pagar esta construcción no hay problema
no queremos que nadie se quede sin sin
visitar la región entonces bueno la
programación es bastante bastante
e
variada variada y bueno va a haber
también un grupo musical que es muy
bueno con fusión se llama y es un grupo
de jóvenes de origen chileno con
quebequenses que hacen una fusión muy
interesante también de ritmos scada
cumbia merengue con todo tipo de ritmos
internacionales que nos van a hacer
bailar hasta más no poder
gabriel garcía del centro para la
inmigración en región de oriente hay
muchísimas gracias por haberte llegado
claramente y sabemos que has hecho un
largo camino para llegar a los estudios
de radio canadá internacional y ahora lo
tenéis que hacer de vuelta pero ha sido
un placer nuevamente estar con usted es
un placer de siempre estar con ustedes
muchas gracias gracias muchas gracias y
mientras que liberamos entonces pasamos
a otro tema y este tema tiene que ver
con la convocatoria que hemos hecho más
vocación para que nuestro público nos
haga llegar cortos vídeos vídeos breves
y fotografías tan fotografías
mostrando no sé qué es lo que pasa es
que la fotografía es difícil de superar
el ojo profesional y distinguido de
pablos barrios
télam
la convocatoria nuestra tiene como fin
conocer el lugar en el que ustedes viven
esta semana no hemos recibido ningún
o si lo hemos recibido no lo hemos
podido encontrar como ya pasó alguna en
alguna ocasión pero si está aquí una vez
más la sesión que ella casi fija de este
programa que son las aventuras de pablo
en la ciudad de montreal
porque nuestros compañeros pablo gómez
barrios hay una vez más con su teléfono
móvil y su cámara de fotos o la cámara
de fotos de su teléfono y registro
imágenes características de algunos
lugares de la ciudad de montreal y él
mismo nos va a contar de qué se trata
cómo hizo para bajar las fotos existe
una pelea que tuve con el teléfono y que
afortunadamente acá mi querido leonardo
me ayudó pero tengo un problema con la
tecnología y es que cada vez que intento
hacer algo hay algo que no funciona sí
entonces le pregunta a leonardo y si me
la tiene
y ya es pero en fin a veces si es eso
otras veces pues más complicado pero
bueno efectivamente
me dediqué a pasear por los callejones
de acá de la ciudad de montreal y tomé
algunas fotos ahí son los callejones del
barrio donde yo vivo lo interesante y ya
hemos hablado de la arquitectura de
montreal y esto forma parte este las
partes traseras de las casas de lo que
vemos cuando vamos por las calles la que
la forma como la ciudad está construida
y tiene siempre detrás un callejón
entonces esos callejones es lo que
intentó hacerle descubrir que son buenos
pues la gente tiene su patio y tiene a
veces algunas veces sobre hechos más
interesantes que el frente de la casa
mayor que vive más atrás
y bueno pues en tu patio te organizas
para estar bien a salir sobre todo para
el asadito y entonces esas son las fotos
no sé si ya las pasamos todas pero con
algunas evidencias de grafitis que que
suelen poner las personas algunos son
interesantes otros menos hay algunos que
hacen unos dibujos que no valen la pena
fotografiar otros sí pues son artistas
finalmente los que hacen esos trabajos
las famosas las masas cuerdas para
atenderla la ropa
en
que casi todas las casas tienen a pesar
de que la mayor parte de la gente
también tenga sus lavadoras y secadoras
igualmente en invierno imagínense ir a
las ropas y la tropa el ayuno entra con
una
y al encontrar entonces las fotos son
las famosas calles traseras que
originalmente tenían un fin mucho menos
este atractivo que era el de sacar los
desperdicios etcétera pero que hoy en
día se han convertido como bien dijiste
en un ambiente más en uno pasa por el
centro con traer los chicos están
jugando ahí porque ahora mucho menos
tránsito y los derivados con lo que
decíamos antes inclusive en algunos
casos hay verdaderas huertas urbanas
exacto y ahora y hay un proyecto de la
ciudad de montreal con respecto a estos
callejones que estábamos viendo ahorita
y que les llaman rivers
berta que son los callejones verdes que
los cierran al tráfico y que los
acomodan para que los chicos justamente
puedan salir y jugar afuera
no se encontrará si los vecinos también
se suelen hacer los encuentros de los
vecinos durante el verano
en esos callejones bueno el agua nos
empieza a inundar así que vamos a ir
algunos segundos de mensajes con
leonardo rapidito aquí y gustavo lo que
dice en áfrica esta cabinda de angola y
cabinda en república democrática del
congo así que les preguntábamos a
nuestro amigo en cuál de ellas estaba
según como lo escribió él está en angola
porque su mensaje dice cabinda cómo está
escrito como en el mensaje de lucas de
gustavo lucas gracias gracias porque yo
la búsqueda y no solo el vídeo y que nos
muestre exacto bueno gustavo también
pregunta desde dónde nos está escucha es
interesando le escucha veedor giovanni
así que pregunta todavía donan y no
contexto daniel camporini saludos desde
monroe y nelson contreras rincón saludos
desde barranquilla junior campeón
muchísimas gracias
bueno el agua que nos inunda realidad es
el tiempo que se privan se nos baje ya
no queda atrás se nos fue a ver entonces
ya en los últimos instantes este
programa los invito a que les
presentemos
nuestro público cuáles son los temas en
los que hemos want ustedes he estado
trabajando a lo largo de esta semana a
quién quiere empezar
muy bien ellos de esta con tema que es
el apadrinamiento de inmigrantes y en el
marco de violencia conyugal es un tema
bastante difícil y como dice
estadísticas canadá es también
todavía más difícil de cuantificar
porque en casos de violencia de conyugal
generalmente las personas que sufren eso
consideran que es un problema personal o
considera o tienen no tienen un dominio
ni del inglés ni del francés entonces
tienen como vergüenza de no pueden ir a
denunciar también está el gallo si
también porque pueden haber tenido
experiencias difíciles con las policías
en sus países de origen y por otro lado
y eso es fundamental tienen tan temor a
ser expulsados oa que los separen de sus
hijos en caso de que se anule este
apadrinamiento entonces este fin de
semana
a tener lugar en montreal un foro muy
importante justamente el primer foro
sobre violencia conyugal y apiay en
general y dirigido a la comunidad
hispana va a ser en castellano la mayor
parte de las presentaciones justamente
por el problema de lengua y conversamos
con ana enríquez ella es abogada
especialista en derecho familiar y en
inmigración ahí en esta entrevista
ella explica quién es la persona que
puede apadrinar a otra persona en qué
momentos etcétera etcétera y ella pone
el acento también en esta violencia
conyugal define un poco delimita cuando
es violencia
ella también dice que la mayor parte de
las víctimas son mujeres pero que
también hay hombres que sufren esta
violencia conyugal y lo interesante
finalmente es que ella habla de que hay
formas de no dejar que este círculo
vicioso se agrave agrave la situación de
las personas que están justamente
viviendo esa violencia entonces
ya dice ante la amenaza del cónyuge de
quitarle el pasaporte o de denunciar a
esa persona para impedir que obtenga la
residencia permanente de que no hay que
tener miedo de eso que canadá se está
dotando cada vez más de maneras de
proteger sobre todo a las mujeres que
son las que más sufren este tipo de
violencia ella habla da un teléfono
donde las mujeres pueden recurrir
conversar llamar también da el nombre de
organismos pan canadiense según la
provincia en donde uno vive hace un clic
en la provincia y está hay una lista de
organismos que ya existen para ayudar a
las mujeres entonces yo siento recibir
entonces puede encontrar toda la
información está ahí y los que viven en
montreal y si quieren ir a este primer
foro de violencia conyugal foro hispano
pues en el reportaje está la dirección
donde pueden ir muy bien pablo si lo
hice muy rápidamente este miércoles 19
de junio
ager el alto comisionado de naciones
unidas para los refugiados acnur
presentó su informe un informe que se
llama tendencias globales y en el que
dice que por primera vez desde que la el
alto comisionado existe desde hace 67
años hubo constataron que hubo 70
millones de desplazados en el mundo el
más alto número de desplazados los
detalles los pueden tener en nuestro
sitio internet
exactamente bueno en este caso yo les
recomiendo un artículo que hice esta
semana con respecto a la nueva supuesta
cripto moneda que saca facebook que si
quiere poder ahora no sólo de la
socialización de la gente sino del
dinero de la gente
con este nuevo entre comillas cripto
moneda y explicó porque de qué se trata
libra se llama y bueno ya tiene mucha
gente en contra antes de salir
porque en contra porque bueno en
realidad
que es el promotor de esto con un montón
de distintas firmas
referencia en
no puedes tener nada privado en pérdida
de privacidad en robo de datos es la
empresa que ha sido la más tocada desde
el punto de vista de la vulnerabilidad
de los datos personales de sus usuarios
y ahora quieren generar una cripta
moneda donde bueno va de plata para
moverla hay adentro sabiendo que las
brechas de seguridad son importantísimas
bueno entonces si hay una fecha para el
lanzamiento de manera supuestamente es
en enero del año que viene
ok bueno quienes no tenemos facebook no
estamos atados a detractores
ok bueno si no se está acabando el
tiempo les agradecemos una vez más de
haber estado con nosotros como cada
semana aquí gracias a ayón ahora gracias
a pablo gracias a leonardo al menos
también y los invitamos a que compartan
una vez más este espacio con todos
nosotros la semana próxima y les
recordamos que el programa está desde
dentro de un rato más disponible para
que los puedan volver a ver y escuchar
en nuestro sitio internet www eres ynet
punto
y hasta el lunes por la mañana hay
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes y
hasta la próxima y mantén los fotos y
madre a otros vídeos y señor gracias a
libertad
[Música]